le film présentait ce soir c'était un
homme amoureux le film de diane kurys
qui fait partie de la sélection
française la projection viennent se
terminer jean jacques dufour en sort
jean-jacques jean-jacques que la fête
commence les 39 marches ium amoureux par
titre de film qui peuvent résumer la
soirée qui vont vivre ce soir pour que
la fête commence et les 39 marches tout
le monde comprend un homme amoureux ces
petites du premier film projeté dans le
cadre de la sélection officielle
un film français de diane kurys avec
comme interprètes principaux greta c'est
cheap et peter coyote à noter la
présence d'un français vincent lindon
qui est un jeune qui monte
les spectateurs sont en train de sortir
et nous attendons jeanne moreau mais
juste avant qu'elle n'arrive je vous
propose de voir un extrait de ce film
qui raconte l'histoire d'une star qui
tombe amoureux d'une jeune comédienne
non
leur courrier
jeanne moreau vous sortez merci d'être
venu déjà c'est très gentil
puis sortez de la projection comment
avez vous trouvé le film de diane kurys
et un magnifique
un très grand film mais je suis très
heureux très fier mais la passion
puisqu'on parle d'amour pendant pendant
deux heures on parle de la vie de la
mort parle
c'est un film tellement
10 tellement fort
en plus c'est une approche qui est celle
des vrais réalisateur ted est qu'il n'ya
pas du jugement pauzé sa personne sur
aucun homme sur aucune femme
les comédiens sont superbes et vraiment
c'est un film maîtrisé un style moi je
suis très très heureuse de leur museau
fait
dites-moi diane kurys explique que c'est
un peu un cliché effectivement à une
star qui rencontre une jeune actrice sur
un tournage ça arrive si grand mais elle
dit finalement quand un comédien joue il
devient ce qu'ils jouaient ce que ça
vous est arrivé ce genre d'histoires
exactement non mais j'aurais pu imaginer
à la place de l'acteur
et puis c'est vrai que du
des transformations intérieures qui
correspond à celle du personnage ce qui
nous permet de nous découvrir et à
mesure des primes
même si on fait de la casse au passage
demain on attend le film de souleymane
cissé lumière est le fils de rossi
chronique d'une mort annoncée donc
rendez-vous à demande pour cette
chronique dans le journal de 23 heures